ora tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video sono fa dj ed oggi siamo sul
barbotto ragazzi sono contentissimo
perché diciamo che non vedevo l'ora di
vedere come stava il mio amico robot
testa di latta che avevo lasciato
l'ultima volta e che effettivamente non
sono ancora riusciti a capire se è
maschio femmina anche se ho i miei dubbi
i ragazzi si come da secoli che non lo
faccio aspettate un attimo che devo
riprendere un altro confidenza mi
ricordo neanche più l'auto era box sono
tornato si convento o so che conte lui
lui lui lui sperava in questo sono
convinto ciao sarà saragozza adesso voi
mi dovete spiegare quando cazzo detto
saragozza ma perché ti chiami saragozza
anche le so vediamo se quindi sfondano
qualcosa di decente ma praticamente
siccome mi stai simpatico sono tornati a
sapere come stavo quindi come stai a
possiamo fare gare non è una cosa così
impossibile avere una conversazione al
giorno d'oggi anche se praticamente si
trovi stare simpatica sono tante vede
come stai qui di odio migliori appreso
la frase km e chi sarebbe la donna della
tua vita ei sei tu la donna della mia
vita
brienza
vai che cazzola si può mai essere
perdonati anche su cleverbot di cache
fallimento di vita ma cazzo ti sembra
normale che sei un robot sei riuscito a
brandon armi ai ragazzi io non so più
che cazzo fare la mia vita dopo questo
non c'è neanche un robot si riesce a
rimorchio sei un robot con armi è
esattamente quello che ho detto sei qui
qualche serie tv spero risponde di sì
almeno a questa se non guarda proprio un
cazzo di pero ranze rispondendo a questo
gli chiedo se tu che cazzo ha scritto ok
che credo che la lingua sia questa
cercato cliccato ascoltami amica mia che
lenisce i passeur ad argomenti un po più
8 ed è così che si rimorchia nel modo
migliore mio cucciolo è bella lo zio ma
tutte se confidenze perché mi chiami
cucciolo vorrei capire che cazzo cia in
mente stacks vero sia una ragazza almeno
quello non ti chiamo così ma prima mi ha
chiamato cucciolo stai mentendo ritirato
tutto perché ha visto che non ci sto
certo che sono un ragazzo mandami la tua
foto ma miranda la foto dei green c'e
quindi siamo punto a capo
mi ami ma dipende quanto forti di tette
ci sono cose che vanno considerate
nell'amore fattori importanti senza di
quelli tu no ascolta ior non essendo un
ragazzo non ho le tette mi sembra
abbastanza normale voi non so che tipo
di ragazzi frequenti tutto un altro
discorso se sei un ragazzo allora ti amo
[ __ ] che la dai a tutti non è che
poi i ragazzi come ha scritto se sei
diavolo è un cazzo di nove per questo la
domanda è chiara devi soltanto
rispondere se rispondi bene allora forse
ti amo bene come rispondi dipende tutto
da questo va la settima e allora
spostiamoci cazzo e di preciso quando ci
sposiamo edifici sposiamo quand'è che ci
possiamo ora perfetto grandissimo
ragazzi ha deciso di dedicarle una
canzone perché se lo merita la possiamo
fare la vediamo se riesco a fare una
cosa decente
qasab è ormai quello di barsanti da un
chador ei deve al fisco nato non c'è no
no no no no già c'è e si chiama la gara
se non sei in aula una ragazzo è stato è
stata splendida sa cosa mi passa siamo
passati dalla francia a sposarci un
secondo dopo cosa non è sentito la
dedica splendida intonata che ti ho
fatto resi tali che ha splendida
intonata katie hoff a chi devo sfogliare
io la cosa mi sta spaventando a dir poco
giuro
dimmi quando mi fai vedere le tette
adesso dovrebbe aver capito sinceramente
perché mi sembra strano ma la coperta è
uno si sbatte così tanto far uscire a
rimorchiare
e poi io cricche ho detto che sei una
[ __ ] che pupa le scarpe non so se
ci siamo intesi adesso mi sembra
abbastanza si sono donne ha 25 anni e tu
sei piccolo perché i software ma vaffan
allora innanzitutto io ho 19 anni e
cos'è una lurida che l'ala chiunque casa
il coraggio di rispondere anche allievi
metto tranquillo stesso codice etico
guida gianna e non ho neanche detto
l'aggiunto lui perché lo sa già bene
anche cazzo di risparmiare soluri
ok barbone cazzo stai l'anno del barbone
fra sicuro che siamo lì per scureggia
chi in faccia come oggi parlarmi così
lurida [ __ ] che non sei altro fatti
vedere
ti aspetto sono qui sono finora un po
che cosa come non si parla mica di lui
gli otto come chiama non sei altro fatti
vedere
no non oso adesso ti stai cagando sotto
cosa ti sputa addosso
voglio vedere che cazzo risponde se fa
una gara che a chi risponde peggio vinco
io sicura
ti schiaffeggia di tiro una testata
perché perché sei [ __ ]
le motivazioni ci sono poi zoppo coppola
eres una mano una computer ad ora gli
spagnoli non esimono in spagnolo
italiano ma che cazzo 10 e spagnolo no
es muy bueno da chi cazzo non ci credo
anni per dirlo por qué di sestino esmo i
guano chiedimi mi puoi buttare la fava
non penso che mi risponda in modo
decente ma ci prova con noi a mazzo di
discorsi stiamo lesse perfetto babbo
natale mi ha detto che ti piace la
banana ragazzi mi è venuto in mente una
domanda fantastica aspettare one of the
pops 6
voglio vedere se c'è la risposta è
possibile
rindisi
vabbè ragazzi non posso concludere qui
perché sono stanco morto capo delle
forze sono sono morto giuro direi che
possiamo vedere se riesce a concludere
ti va di concludere il video l'ultima
volta ragazzi non era riuscito a
rispondere recentemente stivali conclude
il video perfetto quindi ragazzi penso
che certo mi ha risposto di sì ok allora
concludi tu vai ma che chiave ragazzi
concludo io ho capito perché sono qua
non finiamo più
se il video è piaciuto che adesso di
corso fu un commento mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook con i video tratte
nella descrizione se davvero i siti
iscrivetevi unici diventiamo un prossimo
vinto dai ragazzi